and a more attention for who grow up in
seneca i am pleased to introduce number
two normally do is profitability as you
say he is one of those African internal
jobs who spend all their lives
researching study and trying to do their
tests for Africa to have a better place
in this world professor tube is a
Western African history at Columbia
University professor is he said also as
the director of the Institute of African
Studies at sipahi of the School of
International and public affairs and he
has been instrumental in its present
reorganization just bought a PhD in
history from the university of paris
salon prior teaching at Columbia he
taught at the University of Michigan and
before that at Charenton job university
in Dakar Senegal Jeff also serves on the
editorial board of several academic
journals including society journal of
African history and public culture his
research interests include the human
political social and intellectual
history of foreigner and post colonial
Africa his most recent books are black
ostrich on the data or Senegal and it
was published in 2002 and histoire de
senega llamada islamabad off it's a very
very published in 2001 this is Professor
mama reduce please welcome professor
and we will have to pound for
presentation and discussion we have to
forfeit 9200 knighted state and 21
friends unfortunately growth monitors
will not be here the paper would be
presented by so we are ambled is follow
the border for this iPad the first
presentation will be by a man who work
out she is the research fellow of a
polio tetanus massager thanks and that
be a corner much she is also as you see
color at becoming immediately Santa the
papers on Frenchman
and I
thank you thanks for your invitation and
thanks for direction actually I'd like
to focus on the issue of integration has
it is treated confident in French public
sphere and let me talk about integration
actually friends you often talk about
the failure of integration of rational
sense and what's left behind this
failure of integration it's much more
the fear of radicalization of French
Muslims so that's a new cardigan that I
would like you to memorize all the rest
of my presentation is entering between
fear of violence is very sorry and and
the consecutive radicalization of it why
does because actually my rational things
have discontentment about what friends
in offering to them in terms of
integration policies it is really seeing
how the process of political
accountability of citizens to vote their
government it is much more often seen as
a ground for political conflicts and
radical religious radicalization so
ultimately when Muslims in France are
not happy with what French occupation
forces are the huge latin goal of
radical dish the political context is
applied on this depends fortunately is
important to school so that i'm talking
about coal city schools talking about
the school students and statements of
course makers for those four million in
public sphere the challenge of
integration has been making the other
line not what it comes to social
integration non-social extrusion but
further in times of crisis in terms of
cultural policies where infamous seem
hard the main framework what are these
cars is for example well the old salmon
which theater are the more recent riots
and friends the controversy surrounding
bear and the most recent one one around
to best both healthy and having fun all
the controversy around apartment
properties are all these events are key
mothers this is the challenge of
integration of Muslim differences the
result of that is that finally linking
these controversies and if social crisis
in which Islam is involved in a way or
another has gradually replaced the fear
of social extinction by the fear of
radicalization is integration of
vegetables except so there are really
three assumptions that ten behind a
failed integration of most limited
friends first political demands on the
invite for Muslims for particular
protocol demands for greater integration
are even
to credit a station that's the food
section second one is that these
political demands are made under foreign
elements they are made under influence
of foreign exam of the future of
foreign-funded countries and so on and
not made has not emanating from freshman
subscription to desertion is that the
this political demands in which exam
playable for greater integration or the
challenge of the model current French
model of integration I'm not elevated by
the fact that Muslims are other styling
themselves are using mainly future will
be speaking it is exciting that we are
adult free games and that Muslims mainly
religiously speaking so religious
features are all from a constituent has
the main motivation for all the rid of
type of waitresses a medical student has
to have the main reason for majestic the
fresh mobile integration
and this parody has a lot of French
policymakers actually not to focus on as
I said previously issues of social
integration and so on but much more on
the willingness to build a good peaceful
Islam that will be able to not serve
danger of radicalization emanating from
failed integration I am promoting a
general policy and intercultural
dialogue which means that in order okay
there is kind of disgusted that French
model of integration has spellman
customers and so let's try to promote a
kind of intercultural dialogue between
most in because it is certainly there 50
PCT that most in there is a debate of
that further integration so those are
consumption from OS may be different my
bad appearance is this paper on the
contrary in fact this is not actually
the foreign influence is a foreign Islam
or the rejection of the French model of
integration because of a kind of natural
high top of the furnace of scienter
protocol demands for greater integration
but on the contrary water at the base of
the Internet in the internet and is an
organization of French values by Muslims
such as equity equality service attacks
freedom of speech life city mm mm dough
and etc and this in the annihilation of
instead instead let Wilson to merge
Islam when all to use in carmel in our
demands for greater integration that's
enough another so I would like to offer
a real and comic assessment of
assumptions in my paper and you see
currently what is the importance of
oratory drama in the failure of
integration yet that will be my first
time a second thought to be on European
on country d European roots of the the
controversial demands for greater and
clearer and congressional its rejection
and finally I would like to see and to
access what the importance of region and
reaches values as such in in demand for
incentive integration so close Gimple to
the foreign interference and she
answered in a failed integration among
translucence despite of the fact that
now Islam is purely a European region
you have around 20 millions of Muslims
in Europe the inland still seem has the
de facto foreign religion and includes a
lot of policymakers to consider that all
the man strong muscles are foreign are
on the front entrances and they are
driven by other Islamic countries
anything it's true that foreign
influences have an important role to
play in political debates on integration
and so but it needs to be explained
better how and to which channel to which
channel zone so first you have the
channel counselor exam in terms of
external influence on the allegation of
purchases it has been quickly monstrous
this morning that is Mary the way
country's foreign countries such as
Australia such as morrible such as
Turkey and Saudi Arabia actually to take
care of take charge all of the cute or
Muslims when it comes to the
organization of when who comes within
single most for example oranges and
descriptions but we have to underline
that this thing this was having promoted
by the French government itself because
it allows immigrants
to rely on their on these foreign
governments in all in their political
mentor recognition and not to advent in
the next to the French government so for
long for a long time format is having
favorite very French government in order
to manage the richest still I mean one
one concrete example of that is the goal
of the CFC enmity malted crunch comes
the most worship in friend are they
created that the dead Ministry of
Interior psychos in 2003 and that's a
process of elections of local elections
and so on and it was so clear and so
obvious half for example more when
Australia we're trying to put pressure
all their Nationals in order to favor
only staff are related to more open area
where we are talking about your invasion
of Francesca so a cultural not even food
and fun government also have implemented
this kind of foreign influences on on
functions are two very to concrete
example first when they wanted to you in
France what we wanted to expel a
radically new maps they do not all turn
into the process of the
conversation with the genic tell them
expand them because the word comes
through it has the vertical treat you
just expel them to their country of
origin so the idea behind apple's that
radical is not is obviously linked to a
foreign experience and the presence of
already man come on them on the pretzel
all a more compact example in 2004 this
is the the ministry of interior damage
driving periodically where to Egypt to
ask at that time the move T other data
that happy to issue fatwa obliging young
french girls to put out the girl so it
was an effort to promote and paramedic
discourse in order to influence of
divine the kind of integration that
French Muslims should adult you have
also identified
versus the construction of foreign
Islamic discourses and the reason behind
that if Mary Nichols of the lack of God
in French this causes prediction of
future role intellectual and political
dynamic structure so a lot of French
Muslims are running down the discourses
of foreign scholars such as an elderly
for example and it can have a concrete
impact in the widget French mentality of
information fragment book I'm thinking
about a specific fatwa that this car
this age to Calcutta its core issue on
the neat ball coat products that are
seen has scientists or American vehicles
in the middle of the of the war in Iraq
to supersize context and indeed I mean
fractional things and they could not
rely on on internal and engineers French
discourses decided not all there but a
huge majority especially among young
Muslims to lie on this forum posts in
many people like you access what other
European roots of the this controversial
demands for integration all the
rejection of the federal level of
integration sorry first it's true that
the backing of of these demands may be
foreign but the motivation is pure
that's my mistake why God even can take
very extreme example subject the young
French Wilson that are committed suicide
pacts and I had the chance to me to view
some of them before they commit to stop
before the cops come into starbucks in
Iraq six months later and it was so
clear that they're attractive that the
fact that they were attracted by tijada
kind of rejection of the control of
integration most men motivated by their
own experience as French Wilson and not
motivated by the foreign influences of
this whole suit from pouring in vedic
scholars or whatever because through the
nonstick and it almost an erotic or the
majority of them and it was manipulating
the personal experience even when you
have started engine in the center which
is mortal growing and right involvement
for 15 years now in France in Europe at
all to do so here in the US and this
young starting for example rejects also
very much the French model of
integration and some of them decides to
make what they called a visual visual is
an Arabic name which means the
immigration that we should refers to the
professed met from Macau when he was
basically is to maybe not when he was
able to spread Islam hydrogen so it's a
strong import insanity in the mind of
this young French Muslims and we decide
themselves to make very dry and quit
friends as a sign of the rejection of
the French model of an situation and to
go to marry Gulf countries and how can
we understand this move and decision to
quit friend it because they were juicy
hate the French holder of integration
normal it mainly because even though we
are able to reach a certain social group
to our model of integration that in
their opinion ourselves to a vertical so
that are giving with examples to show
how even in the back in may be related
to foreign influences the motivation for
the rejection of the French a model of
activation is curing a french-based the
excitation of the rejection of the
French model integration and also
challenge actually the usual ring that
are male between the ridges of the
French mobile of integration the ripples
to violence and and in the end and the
experience of radicalization let me try
to offer a solution of all categories
first you have what I can call signal
Muslims and focus
we mostly about are rejecting model of
integration first you have the wallet
can behold sick normal sex that's a pure
case I got a perfect example of the
rights that happen in France's 2005
these guys were not observable there are
no free comes in waters they were not
interested in Turkish topography but
they were identified as muslims and to
some extent they also uses I love it yet
boosted our geography of the weekend but
here in challenged very much the
assumption that religion was at the base
of these rights why again through
concrete example so mostly needles
having asked to count down this is right
any favors either be the score was not
rigorously even issued a fatwa seeing
that you know in Atlantic that you come
across it violence and so these these
moves have had no effect on the young
riders and it was the exact site that
ridge apartments were not influencing
overlap at the base of this right this
site song included in verse cemetery
that time is close now bad bad and that
young Muslims were committing inside out
in in December so cyclical things may be
radicalized energy and mingo jets the
French model of integration but it is
much more related to their personal
experience of the creation of social
exclusion then there without the fact
that if you go to a specific religion
second category I would like to Russian
water can be kind of proof that can be
called observing Muslims accident and
she really set up the kind of people are
talking about that's good color Krav
Maga trainer know that is very famous in
YouTube and I mean these are people that
think that Islam should be based for
greater political involvement for a good
active karate citizenship and they don't
consider that being a good citizen
should me in especially infant to get
away from most religious items and here
also coming to the fold big in times of
crisis and and even when they are
contesting and challenged and trying to
not complete but when they are opposite
the French border of integration they do
it to specific real questions if i cant
pretend signature they default the john
logical parties the organized
demonstrations finish
transyl so here also this challenging
that this that a political involvement
based on these activities is made to a
reduction of the French order of
integration third category animals I
would like you Monster again the case of
milk salad so in the sense of what
happened expiring inside they are born
in France for the majority of maturity
of them you have a lot of conference but
actually they simply rejects the French
orbit of integration the just think that
highly ranked is not new hammock models
political model doesn't happen is that
it structures how do you think they
should project the French holder of
integration but he also may indeed
projectable a French model integration
isn't that socialized with normal send
people of course the world works they
constantly can kind of hold it's
absolutely try to limit at the maximum
their direction with normals and anyone
with no product but here also even if
they reject the French model of
situation they are absolutely not
violence lyrics violence and they even
rejects political movement so here also
it is challenging the assumption that
reaches IDK
two containers because politics again is
not written anything want to be and for
example they don't take part to
demonstrations when it comes to handing
the girl I mean you just don't care it
just we have a paper to get to
themselves from each category and I'm
going to come clean if I have again okay
one minute means about real case of
radicalization only region space button
up straight cut you are reserving
actually in order to be just for more
explanation let's take the example of
chimpanzee actions young French most
things that have been involved in chi
evolution again from the experience my
interviews on the ground and from the
elegance of several cases it is much
more than personal experience of social
exclusion of fell integration that is
motivating their involvement in jihadi
narratives in other words they require
themselves because it still all this
becomes the godly their integration has
self and then they look for a radical
group and not the other way around in
conclusion so in a little so I mean it
showing that which is the rejection of
French Quarter reservation has sometimes
leads all in that case became easier to
do with Regis Artemis so in conclusion I
would say that muslin views on what
integration should be losing the
threshold of integration should not be
already terminated by the region's
barrier how to add a try to launch me
there are complex interactions between
national and international for
environments that should be taken in
account at least and have the best we
make and we may try to understand how
different rules are given to in spam in
this analogy to such model of
integration or rejecting and I try to do
it with my for category but in any case
those are not move multiple chopped
Model T choices are actually then
currently process of color negotiation
on what the French model of integration
should be much more than a fixed three
inches perception or rejection of water
catchment of expiration and the real
question now occurs to me that the real
question that is really can't French
Muslims be drawn in political
consultations on the whole of Islam in
process of integration without being
considerate have security assistant
security trade or has been agonizing
element to the French identity
understanding mou systematically the
French roots of finding it wish
the new perspective on the role of
region and integration and it would be
more fruitful to always I always rely on
fri encryption on religious facilities
explanation really the distances by
friend documents and French institutions
to controversial Muslim demands for
integration should not be any more
matter of intercultural dialogue and it
was the case for example during the
calculated our location of concern for
photoshop education with the challenge
of integration of Muslims in depends now
is really to ensure equality about the
variety of understanding of what
archmodels of activation my social
Columbia
the paper will be presented by real-life
man from the anthropology department
needs the title and a private America
they must see me to look Americans
rosemary asked she prepared I'd like to
thank the organizers especially being
invited dissipated this conference and
to offer my sincerest apologies for not
being able to deliver the secret person
i am in California due to a family
emergency and I hope to return in front
of the conference but not to the sake of
for their patience and understanding as
well apology department school
deliverance
presentation is drawn for my
dissertation research and the name of
the paper to change instead of
in 1979 first generation Egyptian
washington DC discussed earlier
Christian Muslim commonality with
scholars a variety of different
conditions and academics methods his
colleague temple university professor
smile of rupee of Palestinian refugee
and helped to organize their Abrahamic
treaty log for that year's annual
meeting of the academic American accents
come me of religion in New York but he
likewise challenge the efficiently what
he saw Erica narratives throughout this
presentation Mohammed Abdullah rose
primarily outlined what United the pre
traditions his opening remarks however
he addressed what he and brought that
what I brought that particular AAR
panels being further than I'm the role
of American foreign policy and
judeo-christian exclusivity in producing
wide-scale was a distress as he told his
New York audience quote we meet today in
a climate of tension caused by recent
events in Iran we do not by any means
advocate or even condone the practice of
taking hostages as a vendor
but the reason events in the relative
arouse in us as well as in any serious
and honest humans deep reflections nay
anxieties over past events of recent
history for decades and listens of Iran
for terranize over by inhumane
containership sorry tortured and made
them the full blessing the collaboration
of the West Palestinians were given from
their own hands by zionist tens and tens
of thousands of payments mathild
tortured roommate while the Christian
West furnish all the political economic
support and supplied the arms and
munitions needed by the perpetrators of
genocide southern Lebanon's innocent
citizens who have bombarded by the most
destructive weapons napalm and cluster
bombs generously given by a nation
committed to so-called judeo-christian
tradition in this and other speeches
Mohammed Abdullah row carefully
navigated the waters cleaning belonging
and at the same time offering fatigue
less than two years later at conference
pacific see about islam enough
Abdul ray and for the basic different
models of Abrahamic progress and
inclusion on the next generation of
Americans that more subtle jet second
generation would be fully American and
US have the ability they maintain to
create more equitable domestic and
international community as a party both
the rising generation of seeking to
equip themselves better education
diversifying their interest
defend the honor of their heritage in
the American environment in this way
they will contribute more great news
Murray of the country of their choice
and also will be able to build a better
bridges of understanding and cooperation
between the United States and Islamic
fatherland creating relationships of
justice and equality after 2001 as I
discussed in the saber to second
generation while some American
intellectuals playboy is attempted to
foster more ethical and inclusive
Abrahamic american-ness their more
recent models of second generation
culture and commonality blood on both
these first-generation Arab
intellectuals efforts to navigate the
waters of belonging and critique as well
as older Jewish intellectuals
sociology's of religious development
these sociology's most significantly
will occur Birds model of American
judeo-christian commonality are one of
the pilot second-generation struggles to
navigate between custom
this as well as between the new
opportunities and vices
american sociological and historical
patterns these patterns and their
stories about second-generation
accommodation and resistance belonging
antique are in turn indebted both to
Muslim philosopher even come dunes 14th
century arguments and to post 9-11 areas
of American exceptionalism but first let
us return to the first generation both
Ismail absolutely end of the road had
trained at al-azhar and in humanities
doctoral programs in the United States
Britain Harvard and so Ezra further both
intentionally frame
American Jewish they did so while
competing important support Israeli
options and Emil
I swear by expanding not just American
this but the kind of atrocities
Americans were created to prevent they
navigate into waters American belonging
and critique in different ways further
they establish the intellectual
framework and institutional members
through which the next generation to
most specifically here laying with some
intellectual spies level row Mohammed
Abdullah rose son and buys asserted
Abrahamic commonality in the 21st
century models GoPro a Columbia
University trained physicist and calm an
emergency room doctor read and at one
time froze assistant email use
sociological paradigms the Jewish
intellectuals or climate well Herbert
deployed to analyze physical solidarity
crucially creating Abrahamic narratives
rope and other Muslim Americans like
burger also criticized American melting
pot models of simulation and the last
year's on second generation
the late practices were ones that
reflected customs overly in the American
on the other more than they reflected
authentic escape please narrative
second-generation religious and cultural
change for shape to the particular
circumstances of 20th century political
and economic developments and massive
demographic shifts nonetheless those to
articulate those who articulated them
all with varying degrees of awareness
use the same 14th century clarity
template even contains universal le
stream even called even had charted the
change from tribal nomadic culture to
find some definite civilization along a
developmental trajectory of four
generations each generation for a new
code was compromised 40 years the 40
years in turn represented the 10-year
career Prophet Muhammad plus the 30-year
in the MOOC edema incontinence
comprehensive introduction to isn't
reversal histories or thought about he
cited the prophets prediction of the
code but after me will last 30 years
then it would be then it will refer to
being tyrannical
already Paul refers Khalifa even
Khaldoun describe subsequent political
dynasties Islamic and otherwise
rosenfeld on the cycle of forty year
changes first generation tribal custom
the second generation settled city
dwellers to third generation for an
urban culture and Anne Tyler
anti-religious trick trappings of luxury
of the good life the fourth generation
was out of tyranny and even help doing
this generational models and theories of
development will change were translated
into colonial policies social theory in
the nineteenth and twentieth centuries
and later became central to histories of
religion and immigration and the
American sociology but it is not
surprising that after nine eleven
discussed further below feisal abdul
rauf premise Abrahamic American this
endless previous models of Jewish a
Christian and Jewish generational change
significantly
models did not evolve decline as rhubarb
you 2003 growth impressions first came
to America within a couple of
generations the religion of seeing a
different character even in the old
world you had differences between German
or anything sweetie so much so that when
they came here and even speak to each
other same thing jus days but after
generation of to a culturally American
Judaism emerged and more than just
cultural we look at what's happened to
JS America so it was my conviction that
the same thing is bound to happen to be
in Islamic experience we can't by
looking at the history of our Christian
George predecessors fort Ellison brought
out
incontinence 14th century topology on
which rose narrative the space
essentially lay in obscurity until the
European
French Orientalists rediscovered his
comprehensive introduction in 1697
bibliothque worry about a dictionary of
titles that thou
in 1806 the first french translation are
published on the first german once in
1812 importantly when L do mysterious
circulated in Italy centuries prior us
as I discussed my dissertation his
models may have compliance world history
narratives
yet to be fully recognize more sending
here being felt in his work was
translated in the early 19th century
Jews honors a French German and British
racial cultural theory transformed into
ponial policy algeria and also turned in
sociology anthropology new colonial
disciplines in British and French
universities meals ircon came to know
beautiful dunes concept of Sevilla which
might loosely translated as group
solidarity from his Egyptian doctoral
student background the same later
British or Angeles and historians such
as on a twenty20 also incorporated with
tokens work into their narratives about
religion zombies often quoted works
history of philosophy
quote is undoubtedly the greatest work
of its kind that has ever yet been
created by anyone in any time or place
well Herbert from the Venus 1955 history
of Christian America agreed mr. ends of
American religion epson signal the
post-world war two period at the time of
enshrining in judeo-christian narratives
in American culture of legislation and
politics and of allowing his greater the
limited access and he subpoenas the
originally formulated by 19th century
Germany called scholars narratives of
Judeo Christian civilization and culture
increasingly mark 12 legislation and
idealized narratives of American
pluralism after World War two well
Herbert's 1955 Protestant Catholic Jew
in SA American police physiology
contributed to this trend even though
Herbert criticized somewhat luxurious
decadence of second and third generation
immigrants and the general culture of
America religion uses insurance paper
hammer and somewhat leftover Muslim
intellectual celebrate
just as mohammed abdullah for example
criticized American Court foreign policy
in his 1979a our address vital drove
likewise challenge the u.s. to fill its
multicultural and pluralist pounces and
armies Abrahamic pluralism includes all
faiths also like Herbert their
narratives highlight the importance of
the second generation sifting religion
from customer a spy's con emigrated
castanic from india as an infant argued
most important things
quote get acquainted with what is
authentically a Islamic and what is not
that means what in our way of life our
customs are dress our gender related
relations are consistent with what
profits that and what in our way of life
is not a challenge in the ball skills
crucially proven is called the advice on
second generation models ones they
promote and claim to my body are shaped
by late 20s 20th century narratives
multiculturalism not helping by the
simulation while these multi cultural
narratives can allow for greater
flexibility and different ways of
articulated belonging and critique they
can also further exacerbate tensions
when she different muscle groups
different groups and the Muslim
different groups of Muslims in the
United States con gave voice to both of
you
upwardly mobile trends of particular
immigrants and different experiences and
different struggles about Americans
Pokemon upper-middle-class suburb I was
definitely different from multiple views
from families not so well my parents are
both doctors and led very busy
professional lives Muslims seen in
America's is very diverse what you have
with an immigrant class that made good
that's a whole is a whole subculture
Indians Pakistanis and erics to
african-americans make up a large part
of the Americas the world with sneak
changes they come from different Cecilia
prakan parents religion was wondering
sentiment and custom rather than examine
practice their sentiments were good but
when it came across in sub-ceo is ethnic
lines and building in at racing
community a component of true Islam
would recognize no difference from one
human being and another based on color
or accurate attributes the embraces less
than robust and according to fun however
second-generation American
different experiences and more open up
boots Loki argue it's fun to be more
comfortable ones given cultural matrices
but at the same time there is more most
definitely a deep-seated racist and
classist element that exists among
Indian and Pakistani immigrants boats
particularly african-americans but that
inquiry doesn't exist in my generation
grew up here so were comfortable with
everybody in contrast to the second
generations perspective the group
solidarity defensive
more of a xenophobia while the cultural
ineptitude and racism of his parents
generation was wicked cognitive but at
the same time the african-american
community needs to understand that a lot
of this is jess culture in other words
is khan went on to explain culture
cultural practices were optional they
were the ones that did not have to
necessarily hinder group or individual
progress in America well if I'm not
attracted to a particular culture
explain I'm not going to necessarily
appreciate our races well aware of
socio-economic differences countenance
possibility of his view that his view of
generational change of progress is
influenced by his socioeconomic status
further he described american progress
and intra
cultural matters brought up as a
self-described second-generation indian
design never felt outside the American
mainstream Khan did not seem to question
the exceptionality of ass America
experience in describing the past and
future of American Islam he nicked
together models of Ko Christian change
her medicine company secularized series
with American narrative progress and
late 20th century multi-cultural harmony
further like his colony laro 21st
century American surprised about define
and is 2004 work on a American that's
titled what what's right with this law
is what's right for America road
sissippi Lee cited Herbert is proof of
American Clarence Thomas Oh Herbert did
not directly site Durkheim and as
functional sociology of generational
change religious assimilation and
American critique he did rely on joining
this history further kia vehicle Tony
beets argument that society's survival
depended on its ability to respond to
moral and religious changes something
the community drive partially
program was primarily an arts of secular
intellectual argued in that time he was
too mystical in his history and the time
we viewed religion as a primary cause of
social problems social change and
politics in economics secondary however
he also agreed with 20 on the declining
piety of upward mobility mobile middle
class generation and what he called the
Toynbee law a little ization in which
humans mistook that their ephemeral
customary practices to eternal ability
for her arm or leg even called you in
the 24 my new specifics of historical
circumstances are crucial and generate
generalizations of difficult to make
however the generational socio-economic
model and economically a deflected
transition via local customs try to
tribal traditions to refined and
possibly definite culture is specific to
go as for how rove and con engage our
groups interval it easy
when accounting for Islam an important
thing to keep in mind is that their
common ancestor if something did not
have a linear progress model of
development rise and decline but now
informative or my arky not Protestant
Protestant or Protestant secular the
seven cousins analysis of the transition
from customs or wine culture was not one
that promised ultimate ability as early
Orientalist translators and commentators
observed even Pelton's Carly even
presents the Messianic model of time and
is worth last year emphasis on ultimate
redemption of others and philosophers
who followed preceded them the two
intellectuals I discuss here though who
are separated from the cultivated by
more than a few millennia and they're
both first generation second generation
ways redemption reform and progress are
necessary elements to generational
narratives for the leo they are the very
basis including
as well as basis for what Islam
contributes to this long is there
forming force for both and
simultaneously traditionally a
progressive protesting at the decadent
lack of social concern and exclusion of
a culturally sophisticated state the use
of ideas about culture and custom I
don't go there American Wilson
predecessor arguments against
imperialism and herb's arguments about
generational exclusions that excess
however both rope and Khan often
abstract these arguments about custom
culture and progress from the economic
aspects central in different ways to
their various predecessors analyses
instead both natural eyes upward
mobility is part of individual and
social progress and speak more about the
creative culture and custom and
detracting authentic religious practice
and they do about politics economics
their gender culture and customs
explanatory models the United States
more than to the exclusion of
socio-economic factors reflects American
liberal discourses of multicultural
to some extent but man Lonnie describes
as culture talk which tends to hide the
political and economic factors through
which identities become meaningful in
different ways in concluding this brief
overview of second-generation arguments
and arguments about second generations I
must emphasize that I do not treat his
model Steven Carlton so as to prove that
American notions of culture
judeo-christian commonality and
generational change are actually Islamic
law reprogramming after all nor have I
done so to make the opposite case rather
focus on how contemporary are convinced
about culture and second generations
both replicate and critique Protestant
and a secularized interpretations of
Athens theories as well as replicate and
critique the exclusions produced by
cornmeal and contemporaries of them
extending the lives and after lives of
unique intense work and its
ramifications articles
I hope to foster first further questions
about history is features and identity
first of all the so called effective rod
in other words they showed red Scout
quickly escalated from local class
republican national controversy and from
1989-90 now the most common
representation as argued that we young
muslim woman had to wear her staff
because they obey their parents so
wearing that scarf as be viewed as the
results of the family pressure and this
representation
New France as a famous book chapter from
Hans family showed this chapter is
called a very woman and his Rhodes woman
and French state during the French
colonization so this disc representation
of its half as a result of the family
pressure is definitely not new
representation of humans remain are
quite different political events in
algeri in Algeria in the 90s and the 911
contributed to spread the idea that for
a radical movement strongly affect the
main religious attitude and to a certain
extent this dimension should not be
overlooked as academic literature has
shown the growing impact of
globalization of attitudes and
identities it need the witness
substantial beginning of nation states
and the multiplication of citizens
loyalties June financial cultural and
military flow however my work in France
shows that the religious attitude of the
young men and women are not primarily
affected by globalization and
international events but whether they
are led definitely admitted in
transition to hard work what does the
transition to have a good mean it means
a transition from
the labor market and the lover
transition from the family of origin to
the creation of a new one the shaping of
of young Muslim beliefs are embedded in
this transition to adulthood and more
precisely in trajectories of schooling
in the labor market and in local
institution transition to adulthood is
traditionally the type of
experimentation but this transition is
now recommend increasingly complex in
France for instance we find an
increasing gap between English and
disconnects between the degree and
position people access inflatable butt
heads we are suffering from a Navy
problem of youth unemployment there is
also a greater competition between young
people of different social background to
access position in the labor market
absolutely I will make sure that the
second generation of non-african
background in France turns apart the
family heritage Islam into single rich
and Martin your resource to become
adults in very complex context there are
different ways of become
and therefore a great diversity of
religious attitudes you want to use the
research findings are going to present
same from long field work conducted in
French video site city near you and not
very far from Geneva I will show that
the Swiss Islamic field contributes to
affect religious attitude of the French
of the young French your museum range I
met beginning because we are angry
witness too much national identities my
field work consisted in in-depth
interviews participant observation and
analysis of local archives first of all
Islam to contradict the school judgments
I would like to sell few words about the
main a good group are going to talk
about the North African population make
your wine into sixties in France they
were menacing your main at this time
and the 80s the possibility of returning
to rights country of origin diminished
and there has been a definite definitely
the definitive settling of these
immigrants with global more familiar
with a liberal education most of the
young people of Norfolk Authority threw
up in muscle families in which neurons
practiced Ramadan and domestic tradition
but most of the neurons did not rate of
five times today or did not make the
makeup liberal age young people of North
African distance definitely distance
themselves from the parent our religious
heritage and the reinterpret religion on
the old way certain religious attitudes
are shaped by young people experience at
school and the feeling of being
intellectually devalued because of the
magnetic they are deep minority origin I
have to remind that young people of
North Africa electrons of product
keeping in mind decided we will become
professional when we become managers
where we have our parents where many
other workers and university will enable
us to access to this tradition of
managers professional and certainly not
valuable workers well when young people
and
young men don't achieve to the high of
secondary school some of them complain
of the negatively levelled at school
because they have no African origin and
they complain of being pushed towards
low-skilled jobs instead of the
professional vocation and lifestyle they
would like to access this is
particularly remarkable at the end of
the cylinder in school when after the
so-called friends over certain two piece
of North African origin still towards
vocational schools where ask over people
or work chilis have a possibility of
going to a more academic institution so
now some young men use religion as a
tool to oppose academic
they attend different groups and
theological philosophical signals to
show to themselves our people that they
are also able to be intellectually
proactive yes as well by becoming a
student in theology for instance and
Italian religious signals young men are
in search of intellectual
requalification and in the field I
investigated telecom adana is a key
figure hmmm who certainly have heard of
the radio telling what Allah this famous
river was boarding Junior box with
saloni in the city in the sixties it all
devised mini religious seminars in
Switzerland but pursuing 2290 in the 90s
psychotic was everywhere in trash not
only in the French Paris marseille in
the Volvo in Strasbourg and also it was
present in my field between your and
Geneva this religious leader is all sewn
into actual tank amazon as PhD in
philosophy and religious studies now he
has to be
yes PhD in Phil's can religious studies
and in seminars alight sporting also
writer and famous fingers is truly truly
intense green space and young men feel
very value with the air when you listen
to tell a comedy it's trying to see how
they want to establish a dialogue with
him at the end of the signals because
they feel that we are students inter
etiology theology when they listen to
Perry come Adam its market much huge
contrast with their position at school
which does not enable young men to have
access to the steady terms of student at
university when we go to the occasional
schools too busy vocational school do
not study philosophy the philosophy for
the moon where else the risk philosophy
in French high schools where they are
participating in religious seminars the
listen to Tariq Ramadan taking the body
philosophers and the respective from the
lens of accurate front of you this
search of intellectual gratification as
also another dimension young people read
books or listen to religious
which spread priests teachers conception
of a slamming in this conception of
Islam the religion is religion is you as
for word for religion powerful religion
which strongly contributed to the
progress of humanity especially in a
matter of science philosophy and
political structure Muslims class as a
webos our food protein it is speaking on
in these goals these religious this
religious perspective give the young
people the feeling of being a descendant
of prestigious history which marks a
huge contrast with the achievement
social situation at school or in the
urban areas to some kind of
identification with each other I noticed
in my fieldwork analyze my till three
world is the fact of restoring the rain
rumination through identification with
Islam this possible type this circle of
identification
in strongly linked to the generation and
more especially to different school
attainments according to the sex
different studies show that young woman
are the most successful a student that
they have made counter counterparts at
one level into educational system and
data services show that because yes data
service so that young woman women are
more likely to adopt participated
participatory videos to remain
concentrated in task to listen to the
professor young woman are more parts to
adopt the behavior of students various
make students appearing appear less
likely to conform behaviors and cause
these gender differences in a matter of
school performance to challenge
traditional roles within the visiting
families and contribute to share
different religious attitudes according
to the cells making a woman I
investigated a successful high school
where we are very as the roller failure
your woman uses them to show their
loyalty to the fire and the case of
seminar some high suspicion
interesting from this point of view this
young woman started practicing Islam
when she became a university student she
had to move to another city I decide and
during her four years studies social
control became much more important than
before for example on saturday morning
at the end of doing a broker's were
employed a design it picked her up and
brought her to the family home and on
sunday evening at the end of the weekend
they took her back to the city where she
worked today for Selena practicing Islam
at this time was way of showing a family
that she was faithful to the family
heritage it was to strike him to observe
that when she completed her studies and
came back to a city teach in high school
she definitely she immediately stopped
practicing in this case young woman
reinterpret religion on the old way to
be able to go ahead with between family
of strengths and search for autonomy I
you soon noticed that some young woman
said to their parents that their Islamic
spiritual insultingly hearts when their
parents want them to practice religion
this is you
and so that Islam is in LA so the
continued family heritage but at the
same time they distance themselves from
the family heritage and they oppose
their parents religious attitudes
organized around the class and rules
regula's some young woman try to get
more autonomy food in the
reinterpretation of this one so no men
try to resolve the male domination the
female higher rate of school success may
makes the young man less comfortable
with money because the struggle to find
a partner and lifting devalued with
respect to the other sets these young
men I don't identify real health
services conception of Islam according
to which woman artist at home and read
children this condition many frequent go
to conservative religious route to in
order to find Buddhist feeling partners
accessible partners organized about
around unorthodox conception of his son
so
what do you do you're what you said
would french-based problem i'll give you
agree with misconception because we see
that school trajectories different
school attainment according to the sex
infinitely impacts on latitudes and not
what happens in algeria or initiative
trace my first venture will be root the
use of the islamic reference numeral
institution my world / so focused on how
young people use Islam in the public
sphere in the public arena and more
especially in noble institution 66 to 80
s the use living the disadvantaged
neighborhood are considered as a target
population by local situation la
poltica de ville it already has meant a
development of several currencies able
to offer many activities to young people
outside outside school hours for the
political I mean it means that we have
to provide different activities
Christ since the 90s social centers have
started recruiting young men of North
Africa background as use workers and
many of them video disc use workers of
North Africa background I've been
university graduates but find a
qualified job and they do feel
ethnically discriminated against in the
French society so remember that there
are graduates they are a degree they
started to be successful in the French
society they went to university educated
but they do not find find quite a
qualified job so when this young man
apply for a job in social centers they
concern we consider it as a second shots
so it's not the job we wanted to access
it's a song choice and they consider it
with a great bitterness they believe
that Webber can be used workers this
should be directors of social centers
because they went to university and we
know where the area and its population
my investigation showed that some of
these young workers of North use workers
of North African background use Islam in
their everyday world who social
centers to impose the middle managers
and even the director of social centers
for instance other one he speaks about
Islam to the two children who go to the
social center to create a greater
proximity with children whether certain
pushing is white non-muslim colleague
aside after the other what he says one
note is was not from the area you yes
what you are not from the area you don't
know the law of African population it
was well not with me so which we see
that abdomen feel things that it should
have harvest position in the structure
and use these Islamic reference to
support this idea that is more qualified
than is correct in over and another case
some youth workers use Islam to
appropriates the social centuries and
lay down the law in the social center
and I investigated the claims of tense
relationships between two young men male
Rasheed and the head Bridget during the
type of Ramadan the head wanted to
organize lecture about Islam and she
said she said too much she said to
maleta machine try to find someone try
to fun fun lecturer who imprisoned the
crew
dimension of Islam using the heart
rather than following rigid
recommendation post use workers invited
an animal a dog to lecture in your
social Center similar social Center
people's haha is a werewolf Swiss Miss
team leader in Geneva and yes very auto
conception of Islam dance culture and
hearts into interview three she told me
to tell of the conference in the morning
police medical to tell me you're
inviting telecom italia hahaha do you
know who is not allowed to come to
France and of course chicken in the
interview by thing I started to be great
panic I didn't know anything about a la
Madonna and I said to my leg comes from
the conference I cannot take a risk but
when I told me I can't call you and show
the telecom so she called Annie Havana
and she was excited she is a while you
two concert the conference speaker me
ever since
a Geneva as skilled still yes so in
methanol she used to islamic reference
to contradict they had recommendation
challenged Authority and appropriate to
social center at the end to complete
below serve a linear transmission of
religion with investing fabulous young
people of North Africa no origin
distance themselves from the parent or
religious heritage and reinterpret
religion on their own way this
phenomenon are so concerned the process
Protestant Jewish and Catholic young
people sociology of religion I'm sure
that are showing that since the
seventies beliefs are being detached
from religious authorities of family
everything and we are witnessing the
prediction of small systems of meanings
built according to the needs which
emerged in the individual biographies
and for example in France that are
already a tradition with sociologists of
riches of religion says that individual
adjust their beliefs to their own
experience everyone takes charge from
themselves of shitty the reference to
the tradition in which they recognize
themselves the relationship with Islam
of the young generation of North African
background is a matter of religious Rico
large in invaded in this time of
transition to have a word and the
reinterpret religion in relation to the
facts and to the house and bounds of
their experience there before understand
the shape of young asleep in religious
attitudes requires deep analysis of
their trajectories and especially to
transition to adulthood which is desitin
in individuals relationship with society
and in the way they define themselves
within society trajectories are built in
the system of social strength of course
it means us to understand Muslims in
Europe so sure
we also met take into account your
family sociology of school so spell upon
sociology and we have to consider the
overall appeal of different factors such
as social class to changing gender
relationships urbanog and ethnicity and
show our this different mechanism shape
role in society and accept position at
school and in labor markets I I've been
involved with the the groom's that I
will be discussing and lastly I worked
with the Council on american-islamic
relations as research director I
developed their annual report on the
status of Muslim civil rights and I
produced some of the literature on a
religious accommodation the various
institutional settings in the united
states that gave legitimacy to looking
at the muslim experience and muslim
needs from this particular angle but I I
left here in Lake 2007 and I'm now
looking at the American Muslim
experience from the outside again I was
looking at them from the inside out
previously so I'm having the advantage
of both of both ways of looking at this
this experience so when I bring with me
is that that first-hand knowledge of the
community and I'm political scientist by
training but although an
interdisciplinary in' always been and
biting political science when we talk
about political actors with our people
who are in the clear for aspiring actors
we deal with them seriously so much of
the discussion thus far with the
exception of you has been related to
interpretation of Islam or cultural
representations of Islam my work is more
about structural factors dr. Carew
talked about it up about that from from
it from medieval
from a legal philosophical perspective I
will talk about political actors in
terms of field players in the field and
there and they were all so my goal
investigating the practical politics of
the Muslim Brotherhood and I my studies
don't try to project the Muslim
Brotherhood as this dominant group that
speaks for all Muslims now I understand
are documented they're a very diverse
nature of the American Muslim experience
and various various levels alpha of
action and thought so but my goal
investigating the Muslim Brotherhood in
the US and its implications for you as
engagement with the Muslim world derives
from observing the rules of self-reliant
Islamic groups have played in American
domestic scene and from assuming that
word Pakistan in the United States has
not reached its potential this research
is based on three major sources
first-hand knowledge as called activist
the empirical data that I collected
through my years at at the Council on
american-islamic relations and of course
for a library research that helped me
identify the sources and the different
perspectives under questions and
concerns addressed in this paper to
understand how the Muslim Brotherhood
could fit in the larger picture of
American apology this paper
built on the work of Harvard professor
Tony Snell on how citizens with foreign
attachments have influenced not only
domestic and foreign policy discussions
but also the very nature of the American
political system several historical
factors have exerted pressure on the
very character of American democracy as
outlined earlier this morning by dr. oz
mod K and we just summarize them very
quickly here many immigrants arrived in
the post colonial period with ethnic and
religious awareness including Muslims
who had experienced islamic revivalism
joined a society american society that
has moved to acknowledge its own
diversity the civil rights movement in
the 60s was followed by the wives of
multiculturalism american involvement in
the world has grown tremendously as the
u.s. rose to a pre-eminent power
position with globalization at the end
of the Cold War Americans have become
part of the outside world and the world
has become part of America given the
openness of the American political
process to a wide range of lobbying in
important Affairs it would be surprising
if Muslim activists have not effective
policy debates in Washington indeed
September 11 has caused a sea change in
Washington's attitude toward political
stem for good or bad the movement with
its extremist and moderate
manifestations is now seen as a player
in global politics how efficient is
American government is interpreting and
dealing
islamic activist that's that's something
we can answer once we know who these
people are what they what they want and
how they affect the public discourse in
America Tony Smith contrasts three major
visions for the new American democracy
multiculturalists nationalist and
pluralist and I suppose this discover
much of the of the manifestation that
were presented in the earlier papers
assimilation ISM has always been the
preferred option in the nationalist
discourse multiculturalists would define
their goal in terms of our peaceful
coexistence between all groups including
the new entrance and obviously that
should include the Muslim Brotherhood
who are now American citizen pluralist
that's where Tony Smith and I do on
share the value of the adversity with
multiculturalist but share with
nationalist a commitment to a
generalized rather than particularized
inception of American citizen who rule
is however can see that because of the
faction of nature of American civil
society there could be multiple
definition of what is in the best
interest of the general public which is
coming through the ARCA the paper too
to meet the most important parts of it
given the fact that much of the public
debate about Islamic activism stems from
policy concerns in places where America
has few friends among radicalized
populations and the heightened Public
apprehension about the prospects of
terrorism in the call then it is a 42
time to raise the question whether
American Muslim activists such as the
Muslim Brotherhood in America although
still small quantitatively speaking but
very influential especially among Arab
Americans who practice the faith it is
the largest segment of that of that
community in terms of in terms of
organizational expression it is a 42
time to raise the question whether those
Muslim activists can we count it out to
stem the tide of radicalism in the
Muslim world by first becoming
incorporated into America's pluralistic
democracy the second objective of this
paper is to address the ethical
questions surrounding argument
specifying the rights and obligations of
Islamic citizens in American democracy
given that American Muslims with foreign
attachments are only one of the above
manufactures presenting domestic
political system questions arise arise
about their justification of the
attempts by the competing groups to
define the American policy in general
Smith proposes rules for responsible
citizenship that are used as framework
in this paper 22 rules that he present
particularly
and one no faction should work to
further the agendas of foreign groups or
governments regardless of thinking in
Washington or America at large to
fraction must respond to fair criticism
of their demands and their activities in
ways that deal with the merits of the
charges against now before I go in to
apply it with this framework of
democratic oralism and responsible
citizenship to the Muslim Brotherhood
let me just touch on how this circle cut
up compares to the fridge distance would
compare it I I think um if Torrey Smith
with the would examine all the testing
center back dress it would point out two
things to important feature that kind of
explains why the French would be more on
the National dis- beside then then what
that Americans demographic change is a
factor American America's demography has
has changed much much more dramatically
than than the first demography although
there has been a rise in the number of
Muslims in in France and of course the
issue here for America is it's not just
Muslims of them the number of Muslims
Muslims in France but Muslims are part
of a larger much growing minority
population in the US the other course
important factor is the position of
friends in local affairs visit gave the
power position of the of the US which
makes the print more kind of insular in
there they're looking ended up and more
dangerous okay so all right and so now
what do what do they was the brother
would have to to offer so let's start
with that Robert lichen and Stephen
Brooke fellows with the Nixon when the
Nixon scepter hardly a beacon of
multiculturalism identified mutual
interests between the US and the Muslim
Brotherhood and here they're talking
mobile was the brother with his
organization that has 77 chapters across
the goal so they are you defied the
mutual interest in terms of opposition
to al-qaeda the encouragement of
democracy and resistance to expanding
Iranian influence and of course they
propose dialogue where with this group
and specifically started with Muslim
Brotherhood reformist especially those
who reside in the West yes the focus on
the Muslim Brotherhood environment okay
the I go event into their history and
how they are they occurs some of them
came back in the 50
later in later decades fleeing
persecution in in their countries of
origin Egyptians and the later the
eighties in the Syrians the Iraqis but
most most of them came as part of the
post 1965 immigration wave and while
some of them came as will training
professionals doctors engineers a lot of
them came as foreign students and they
kind of decided after after graduation
and getting good jobs or taking American
spouses to to stay and become American
citizens but no sooner was the
Brotherhood members arrived to the to
the US in the early 60s then they began
looking for places of worship on
campuses there they met other news and
who shared immigrants to this world who
share their interests including some who
came from south asia had affiliation
with the Pakistani jamaat-e-islami
together they created the Muslim Student
Association ms a starting in a meeting
at the University of Illinois in
urbana-champaign in 1963 out of this
grew the Islamic Society of North
America which in my view now is the
premier American Islamic movement in the
United States that has had some overlap
in history with jamaat-e-islami and the
Muslim Brotherhood
students who later then split from a
sauna and decided to pursue action on
their own and of course with that the
slotted International Islamic is the
international institute of Islamic part
with their premier scholar Taha general
Wiley who developed this concept of
chicken yet minority jurisprudence now
all these groups at splitting from or
some of them some of their leaders
splitting from from the Houston
Brotherhood which at the time was still
an underground culture and underground
movement primarily because dominated by
foreign students who returned better the
return back home in countries where the
Muslim Brotherhood was not allowed to
operate in the open was not legal so but
the rise of group splitting from the
Muslim Brotherhood informing successful
national and international organizations
caused the Muslim Brotherhood leaders to
feel somewhat marginalized by the late
80s the Muslim Brotherhood became
cognizant of the fact that
any of the members have acquired
citizenship and settled in America after
receiving jobs and they decided to
pursue a policy of idea Anthony Jennings
going public as opposed to a secretive
organization seems like I still have to
work ok so what they decide when they
decided to go public they even change
their name they didn't call themselves
who's the Brotherhood although there was
not they would have nothing illegal
about it but they adopted the name
Muslim American society and they changed
they expressed their mission in ways
that did not address the the etiology
that they brought with them or that the
geology they walk with their in in their
and their countries of their countries
of origin mass remain silent on key
goals of the of the International Muslim
Brotherhood the gold they adopted
proclamation of unifying Muslims stress
sonic values to relate to the non-muslim
surrounding the applied perception of
common ground values promoting
participation person to nothing virtual
world society he will announce that his
plan on the nation of human values at
this land besides Brotherhood
the justice mercy compassion and peace
but they remain silent on two goals
establishing of static state and
liberating the Islamic nation from the
Muslim occupation also mass boostin
american society named silent on the
traditional muslim brotherhood
categorizing of the world into
muslim-majority lands and others where
muslims are in the minority and under
that conception the vision that was
officiated in 1994 by the international
organization of muslim brothers
envisioned I the participation of muslin
majorities and minorities under the
concept of uma that seeks international
cooperation in the building human
civilization on the basis of balancing
spiritual and material needs mass would
have been a lot more honest with with
other Muslims and American public at
large had they addressed those important
those important goals and envisions out
of the of the Muslim Brotherhood
question why insist on muslim solidarity
in an age of pluralism and global
interaction american minorities invested
their internal solidarity so as long as
they pursue this via legal means no one
would stop them sometimes the US
government even overlooked in this
behavior of minority group leaders in
their attempt to keep their members to
lie muslim brotherhood leaders can be
authoritative but American political
culture respects the economy of
non-government organizations pluralist
would not as a matter of principle
objective minority solidarity so long as
it is pursued without expectation of
assistance from the state thus far mass
has pursued survival through adaptation
Shannon away the paths of undergrad
activism establishing organizational
autonomy and watering down the
expression of their ideology I have a
section of the Palestinian numbers but
some people are interested maybe we can
go over these Nvidia Q&A session just
for the benefit of the time I'm going to
skip that the terrorist attacks of
September 11 resulted in a range of the
facts of Islamic activism although the
US government began to open up to
moderate groups of political Islam
overseas domestic law enforcement
agencies look at the Muslim Brotherhood
and other groups with decreased
suspicion organizations and leaders with
his shoe
creation to overseas groups implicated
in violence we're now identified as
either a threat or potential threat now
from the perspective of democratic
pluralism the ultimate test of loyalty
lies in the reaction of Muslim
Brotherhood members to US commitment to
a power in wisdom majority lens the
Muslim Brotherhood here and abroad
actually exhibited diverse responses
Muslim Brotherhood leaders and groups
with historical affiliation to the
Muslim Brotherhood gave the condition of
support for US military action in
Afghanistan they opposed the Iraq war on
grounds that it was illegal under
international law although they have not
contemplated the very legitimacy of
international conventions on war and
peace but this has left some national
Muslim Brotherhood factions freeze act
of their own regardless of common wisdom
of their fellow members some of our key
was the relevant members align
themselves with the u.s. just as the
Kuwaiti Muslim Brotherhood in America
and outside america in Kuwait did during
the 1919
91 golf or after September 11 the Bush
administration announced a new policy
direction in the arab-israeli conflict
that hopes food establishment of a
Palestinian state this was a huge relief
for Palestinian American Muslims
including Palestinian members of the
Muslim Brotherhood encouraged by change
in Washington some Palestinians within
the council on american-islamic
relations led by board chairman omer
ahmed push the table increased attention
to the cause of their kinfolk but they
even offered complete ideas nor did they
even exhibit an understanding of the
difference between approaching the
question of palestine as a reflection of
ethno-religious passion and addressing a
national policy issue from an American
Muslim perspective this is a newly
decision of care principles to suppress
well I go this previously when Ken was
established mainly by umar uthman and
and then he had a wife both are
Palestinian both came from history of
activism in installing Association for
Palestine which was pro Hamas before
Thomas was involved in violence and was
a policeman the terrorist list they
split from it and they stabbed started
care they decided against my
recommendation at the time I wanted to
progress into defining their identity
and starting we're looking at how as
Palestinians and one
American can can pursue a path of public
discussion and activism in the public
arena instead they decided to to just
not do anything about Hamas until a few
years later they kind of woke up and
decided wanted to talk about Palestine
and we have to do something about
Palestine so that kind of hunting them
back after nine eleven and led to a
power struggle at the cannes board that
ultimately ended up with o muhammad saw
and resigning resigning his post care
had already established a policy that
whatever we do on a scare whatever care
does on on this issue has to be done
from the perspective of addressing a
according policy issue can continue to
pursue public advocacy on its main main
focus which is the status of muslim
supervisor in the united states kara
critics however stepped up their attacks
charging that care has the project phase
that is radical they cited in the past
involvement we have a weapon in the sun
association of palestine and his past
favorable mention of hamas awaaz refusal
to offer straight forward answer to this
charge is ironic because care has a
well-established reputation of being a
community independent and some of care
founders special o muhammad had a
history in tlie induced
so that's that's the link if you just
ask YZ talking with this decision
critics believe that I was sympathies to
Hamas could still be intact a more
logical explanation based on my
observation and my first-hand knowledge
we have an okay Dianetics is that he
represents a case of divided loyalties
he is now the unchallenged leader of
care national encourage daily operations
yield to his assimilated American Muslim
aids including his own wife but in
private meetings with political leaders
is Palestinian passions dominate his
conversation is the basicness are on
Hamas is very ironic because now Hamas
leaders separate himself from the past
Patrick of the group even its founding
charter I can I deal with this in a
individual paper part okay so let's let
me just wrap it up here mass which was
an education and social service kind of
movement after nine eleven feeling now
that the Muslim Brotherhood especially
after members of Congress world to Egypt
and insisted you want to eat with with
members of the Egyptian parliament who
belong to the Muslim Brotherhood after
nine eleven felt that the Muslim
Brotherhood became under the
cap and so this they declared their
affiliation with quickly with the Muslim
Brotherhood movement and they equal
claim that the sense of American Muslim
identity is based on the teachings of
the Muslim Brotherhood movement although
they have not explained what that what
that really what that really meant and
that and that continues to be a major
challenge and at a major background
through which the US law enforcement
have dealt with law enforcement actions
after nine eleven a good bulk of the
groups that have been investigated a
shutdown and and prosecuted have a
history or were part of this network of
people who are Muslim Brotherhood or
heavy stream that was super early
movement and the fact that they're not
producing real good asset they're not
showing how they have progressed
throughout the years from past the
creation of the Muslim Brotherhood
ideology to this American Muslim
identity cause this suspicion and from
torrey smith construction of democratic
tourism and his rules of a responsible
citizenship yes they owe the public and
explanation and they have if they
haven't really reach an explanation they
can attach themselves to people my party
promoter I think thought of Ramadan but
what I can hold on is trying to do is to
America
the Muslim Brotherhood vision that's
what he's doing although i can tell you
when I when I when I develop the the
care report on the status of course of
civil rights I found that accepting the
legacy of care actually that advocating
for Muslim clients by attaching yourself
to the Constitution and to equal
citizenship rights would be more
profitable to Muslims even looking
strategically at the issue then trying
to establish a claim that we are a
Muslim minority that is loyal that is
that is cognizant and aware of the of
the majority in in the country in which
we are citizen and we're trying to just
act like nice nice people actually with
math jump into the fray of oakland curve
advocacy they mimic cares approach so we
can talk
focusing on processing active and not
appear where Daniel how must floors open
wider to find yourself and comment or
ask questions so I think we have roughly
20 minutes quick question about between
12 ml about the third point because my
understanding body police are trying to
build an Islamic state guard a majority
answer to implement Islamic law and
their minority a new issue diverse but
when you look at the former quick
example first for graduation the first
one to use their secular rightly the
other one some inspired exactly
the third possibly fundamental 70 and
the fourth one had some political event
but hard to define a not depart together
for as both the Sun is therefore the
batter we use control all the Islamic
activity snowboard the trouble I went to
order what question is would fail to
define terrorism I mean Christ was a
security in a western act yeah and then
one may say that modern email strike two
22 it's amazing mr. muhammad respond
Sheree Rose i canna
finally liked as anyone on them there's
been some speculation about the
difference between a place like are
saying and Paris as to why you riots
happened in Paris Lyon 2005 our saviors
in either city is it the bonding problem
or they have better reaches maybe you
can you can impress that place
my question is addressed which will be
right up specifically to dust we had
other respect to your findings new
research about how Muslim Jamison are
sealed in France are you from it's just
can be extended to those for a Frenchman
who originally are from the sub-saharan
Africa or is just focus on the rocks
north part of Africa
from sri krishna and actually the
response is going to be quite simple i
was doing to present a paper on the
evolution of protocol exam and as chief
topic had a last minute so that's who
our title was not flipped clink what I
discuss tonight deeper but I didn't
mention population and I've talked about
the Catechism indeed now the less to
answer your question that's the exact
challenge of explaining what political
Islam is not currently in Europe all the
West at large because this is a golden
uprooted future that took place first
and foremost in the Arab and Muslim or
and then have been truthful transplant
eight transfer takes in in Europe and in
France in particular and my quick
explanation of a quick analysis way to
do this work on political Islam is that
political Islam and maybe the most
important would kind of political
inspired kind of protocol in particular
I've been transmitted to mechanisms that
Natalie had described actually you know
this importance of cheating
giving confidence to young fresh mostly
Lancelot but that was in the 80s and in
the seal the middle of night it and then
young French Muslims have we adapted and
we involved this course these particle
is records in something else and his arm
is still for even texting is currently
in Europe the main the first reference
of the first resource for the definition
of their ability or the political
identity of the political class but in a
total different connection with the
stage for example always the look at the
west and the enemy I mean all these
receptions and all these narratives of
Chandler's I would answer the question
of mad scientist defense since between
the two cities and variation on the bear
and differences between not african
community and cesarean what i would say
that it may be relevant for the
immigrants animation but for the second
world or young muslim girl girls boring
friends being from having it up ever
enough african or strips are in
background i would say that the way out
of the veil is much more and acting it's
much more linked to the way we perceive
their ok there too sorry there are two
main features first generation wall the
way melody all subside on fire no too
tiring african girls wearing the male
mid 90s is not the same way they are
why because of the 90s it was really
seen has the courage side as assigned I
mean that was challenging the main
picture and mentally culture it was sad
it Wilson have a controversial decision
both among the parents of whiskers and
among any new tab expect between the
last occasion really of the sense of the
veil I mean you cannot have this
explanation anymore and you have a lot
of girls now who are wearing it in there
without being connected at all to any
kind of political name stays on it up so
you have a generational faction and you
have also the kind of region since all
the the kind of political ideologies
that we are opposed to so to answer your
question in for people who are conniving
themselves to some of England tariffs
and metallic another kind of discourses
the veil is try to be not be to be an
obstacle to their social and political
integration why girls are wearing kind
of therapy there is much more seen as a
sign of social distinction and it
identification and specificity mera
we suck
well to answer your question very very
straightforwardly the answer is yes I
think Tony Smith offers a very very
useful framework that can help us
analyze u.s. foreign policy action and
domestic policy and also understand the
place of the Muslim Brotherhood and you
can apply to other groups as well and so
actually after meeting Torrey Smith I
impact at what I have done a care since
I joined him in 1996 and I was applying
a pluralist a pluralist model in in the
way I constructed research projects at
the Council on american-islamic
relations so the answer is yes
absolutely max alien virus somehow
scholars studied over 30 days in 2005 in
the Paris Area and they showed that rip
reloads robots started from areas where
we find very strong ethics
and the place where Ryan started was in
keisha's world englishes one there is
value out there fetishes voice velocity
high level of unemployment letter so a
very aware we find the most important
level of the pics of relational trance
seventy percent of the diarrhea is
comprised of population of minority
background so the case of Lisa Greg's
especially interesting but there is not
only the case of fishes relativism sell
so many different disadvantaged
neighborhood around Paris so I think the
characteristic of ethnic segregation
combined with high level of unemployment
schools failure at school are definitely
very important in Marseille the cases of
Messiah is really interesting because
they were Maria rights where else the
railroads in France many many cities but
only marine services has poor human
liver and so on and messiah as a beauty
ethnic identity for a very long time and
maybe maybe young people in a sale of
North Africa background a steam coming
from a sale we are Marcia there is a
strange sense of belonging where else is
much less the place in France the reason
so strong not strong sense of
but also very strong association created
by the pretense and they do a fantastic
work to establish a permanent dialogue
with young people or people between
local treaties of not defending people
but the fact that there are no results
in relative alerts rails rails in
Marseille does not mean that it's
working very well there they were mainly
probably muscle mainly problems well
it's true that this strong sense of
belonging and very high yes social
networks neighbor provocateur prevented
riots yes and you have to say that in
France control between ground for
example you go to Ingram you have the
question to agent people young age
people many of them say we feel British
when I went there I was so surprised
where do you come from I am British
there is there is no the most of the
time there is no prob everybody's
whereas in France it's much more
complicated many people if you got us
know that we can
people of North African background they
don't sell refill French the difference
there is a white panel of wide diversity
of belongings were saying I feel fresh
it's it's not easy to hear this in
France my name is Bettina graduated i am
american and i would like to know if you
guys have thought about the challenge of
integration in context of the history of
muslims in america going back to before
Columbus I'd men sir thomas one scholar
Sylvia youth is another one I would like
to mention it up sailor who was one of
the first American revolutionaries who
was a martyr is lastly what flung
actually he was Muslim so I think the
history of Islam in America should be
examined as a to help create tolerance
for this law in America and I put a
malaria outside that I have my own
perspective around history I would like
to share thank you
a comment of the coma well let me
quickly is how he surfer Islam is being
appropriated by using actors by a
government official who wants to repeat
that history to legitimize membership in
American society so it's an ongoing
process a recent example is the 20 movie
called the prince among slaves which was
a
last of us
just said I think it's very interesting
doing that I thought that's what we were
trying to do here and we are not going
to open it comment thank you very much